catherine for you what did you think
about izzy stevens
and dr karev ending up together
on grey's anatomy i didn't see it so i
don't know what this is you didn't watch
it
i didn't it's not about work or you or
joe
it's about me i left
[Music]
and i'm with izzy i don't know wasn't he
with someone
he was but then he left her to go and be
with izzy which i thought was
that's an a-hole move i'm sorry
katherine heigl finally addressing karev
and izzy's surprise grey's anatomy
reunion
and if you will go back to that show
with all these other cameos happening or
you're focused on this show now i'm
super focused on this show
and my passion for it and um yeah that
i i would never say never but it's not
likely i'm sorry
that's fair this show is so good and
people are just gonna love it
that show she's talking about is firefly
lane
it hits netflix on february 3rd i cannot
believe you picked me over clooney
me neither the series follows the
friendship of two women
through several decades like i spent
weeks putting together like my vision
board of what i thought tully's 80
kind of vibe was going to be like what
her hair should be like what her
makeup should be like and all of that it
was just so fun
and creative to uh dive back into that
decade it's it's
wildly different
than anything
you